[Music]
when you found me in that hole that they
put me in I got you why did you help me
because you needed help
I will help you if I thought I think the
thing that got me the most excited about
being a part of the flash was just
playing a superhero well then maybe you
will need this
you're a Supergirl
Sasha came in with a lot of strengths
and immediately I thought that she was
the perfect Supergirl I remember
graduating college
the dough is on there as Wonder Woman I
now feel really blessed like I am
playing Supergirl would you like to fly
hard I was like am I getting
a double she yelled him across the
rivers oh you don't need one she trained
like crazy she was very determined and
having fun with it
character like the Supergirl that we've
created it's not just the inclusion of
Supergirl that is reversive but also
bringing a superhero that doesn't look
like super girls let everyone know you
know what this symbol stands for means
hope right I wish I would have a hero
like the Super Bowl that we've made when
I was little
she is a badass
[Music]
hi I love you thank you crushing you
into Mr Wayne no please don't stop
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
hey Bruce I can fix things I can save
people I could save my mom I could save
your parents
thank you
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school school was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die again
right
it's not Quark my name is Cara I will
help you
interesting group what's now
wait he's Batman
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
we're in unguarded territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
we have fancy friends
yo it was an Uber
exact
[Music]